autofahrende umweltfreunde haben sie in
Wiesbaden nicht leicht diese Erfahrung
muss auch Junis Marie dörband machen
innerhalb weniger Tage kassiert sie drei
Knöllchen der Grund die fehlende grüne
Plakette für die Umweltzone Frau dörban
versteht die Welt nicht mehr denn ihr
Elektroauto produziert 0 Abgase hat noch
nicht einmal eine Auspuff trotzdem soll
sie knapp 400 € Bußgeld zahlen mir
persönlich ist die Umwelt einfach
wichtig und das ärgert mich dermaßen
dass man mir Vorbild ich hätte den
Verstoß gegen die Umfeld begangen obwohl
ich so sehr darauf achte ich war
wirklich also ich habe mein Auto hat
keine Abgase und ähm ja dass man darauf
gar keine Rücksicht nimmt das finde ich
echt traurig
Junis marie dörpern hat sich ganz
bewusst für das emissionsfreie
Elektroauto entschieden Ende vergangenen
Jahres bekommt sie plötzlich in nur ein
paar Tagen drei Knöllchen sie weiß nicht
warum auf den blauen Zetteln der Stadt
Wiesbaden steht auch nicht was sie
falsch gemacht haben soll telefonisch
erfährt sich schließlich an autofäle die
grüne Plakette geduldig erklärt sie ihr
Auto produziert keine Abgase das ist ein
Elektroauto ist kann jeder am e auf dem
Kennzeichen erkennen egal die Bußgelder
bleiben für viele Wiesbadener ein Witz
ich vermute dass das die das Vertrauen
in unsere staatlichen Institutionen
nicht gerade stärkt also ich finde es
gelinde gesagt bescheuert dass man
hinter normalen verbrennermotoren oder
verbrennerautos hinterher ist kann ich
verstehen jetzt aber hinter Autos her zu
sein die ja ursprünglich eingeführt
wurden dass man einfach mehr für die
Umwelt tut finde ich nicht richtig davon
habe ich gar nichts dass die Damen
bestraft wird man sollte diese Leute
eher unterstützen der Fall von Frau
dörpern liegt mittlerweile beim
Regierungspräsidium in Kassel dort heißt
es wegen einer Verordnung aus dem Jahre
2007 sei eine grüne Plakette zwingend
erforderlich allerdings prüfe Mann ob
eine mehrfache Verfolgung desselben
deliktin kurzer Zeitspanne zielführend
ist oder ob das Verkehrs erzieherische
Ziel nicht bereits durch einmalige
Ahnung erreicht wurde klingt so als
bekomme Frau da Band ein Teil des
Bußgelds erlassen dass das ganze
Verfahren und sie nicht ist sieht die
Behörde nicht
es hat sich mittlerweile schon so viel
verändert und es waren so viele
Elektroautos auf den Straßen das ist
einfach dringend einer Überarbeitung
bedürfte wohl oder übel hat Junis Marie
dörpernt ihr Elektroauto jetzt
plakettentechnisch nachgerüstet damit
sie endlich mit ihrem E-Auto durch die
umwälzone fahren darf